uno de los grupos más grandes que ha
ocurrido en la historia
del mundo que haya sido registrado el 11
de marzo de 2011 estábamos en japón en
una visita técnica
y después de hacer la visita técnica a
un laboratorio de terremotos y tsunamis
empezó este terremoto real este es una
imagen en una estación de televisión
como pueden ver ustedes todo el
equipamiento comienza a moverse
y lo que había pasado que había empezado
un terremoto muy grande como le digo a
los más grandes que se han podido
registrar en toda la historia de la
humanidad un terremoto de grado 9
seguido de esto como el terremoto había
ocurrido frente a las costas del japón
en el fondo marino estábamos de regreso
a tokio sabíamos más o menos viaja 250
kilómetros al sur de tokio
estábamos regresando y en este bus había
doctores de ingeniería
había este profesor de ingeniería
sísmica había más o menos 20 personas
dentro de este bus
estábamos viendo las imágenes del tiempo
real de lo que estaba ocurriendo en toda
la costa japonesa y realmente nosotros
viste comenzamos a discutir por dónde
regresar y saben quién tomó la decisión
cómo regresa el conductor del bus
vendedores de ingeniería y toma la
decisión es el conductor del gusto
porque porque tenían su protocolo y eso
es lo que queremos desarrollar
protocolos de acción o de este
contingencia para cualquier evento
interesante estábamos regresando y ya
estábamos viendo los resultados del
tiempo real lo que cosa iba a pasar en
los siguientes minutos hoy el lo que
queremos hacer ahora es representar de
alguna manera lo que ocurrió y
justamente lo que estamos viendo acá es
un modelo tenemos modelos numéricos del
sótano y este profesor que ustedes ven
ahí de los 1500 que el profesor imamura
ha desarrollado un software el cual
permite hacer esa simulación
entonces lo que hemos hecho es mandar a
capacitar chicos de acá del audio a que
aprendan estas tecnologías y hacer una
transferencia tecnológica y esta
transferencia tecnológica aplicarla a
nuestra realidad como ven ustedes ahí
esta simulación
hay varios parámetros con la distancia
que hay entre el origen del sismo y la
costa eso va a determinar el tiempo la
forma del fondo marino para determinar
también la altura en tiempo de llegada
de las primeras olas a la costa y esta
cosa no serviría no serviría así que
podemos captar estas ondas sísmicas nos
podría servir para generar un sistema de
alerta temprana contra eso también para
hacer qué cosas la evacuación
y esto puede pasar en perú
definitivamente sí
en algún momento va a tener que pasar
acá tenemos esas líneas rojas que
ustedes ven ahí indica la longitud de la
línea o la longitud de la ruptura que
generó un signo el del año 2.746 donde a
hace 272 años
y los hijos se generan por acumulación
de energía en este caso la placa de
nasca está empujando a la placa
sudamericana y que cuando está pasando
se está
se está concentrando la energía que en
algún momento tiene que ser liberada
entonces pero tenemos evidencias que
hayan ocurrido también en el perú claro
que si ese sismo de 1.346 generó un gran
tsunami que según obviamente todavía
habían fotos no había televisión
obviamente no había registros de ese
registro
de algún tipo de dispositivo en ese
tiempo obviamente pero según los relatos
las evidencias no se generaron también
bastante grande y que pueda seguir en la
historia fílmica de cualquier lugar si
esto ocurrió un siglo de un determinado
tamaño en algún momento de su historia
este sismo va a volver a ocurrir cuando
no sabemos y para eso hay que estar
preparado justamente sabemos qué va a
ocurrir un sismo pero no sabemos cuándo
pero cuáles son las ideas para que se
genere un tsunami no todos los sismos
generacional hay que cumplirse estas
condiciones como por ejemplo la magnitud
del sismo un sismo pequeño este es un
análisis en mismos los sismos pequeños
que están acá al lado izquierdo de esa
línea azul diagonal eso no va a
solucionar
pero los hijos grandes están a la
derecha ellos se iban a producir sonar y
el tsunami va a depender mucho del
tamaño del sismo y de la profundidad
obviamente mientras más superficiales
del sismo obviamente vamos a tener un
sismo y un tsunami mucho más grande pero
conocerlos
tenemos evidencias de generación de
tsunamis frente a las costas del perú
tenemos el sismo del año 96 y 22 en el
año 96 1 frente a chimbote el otro
frente a también claro que no fueron
sismos que generaron su también muy
grande el sultán más grande y reciente
que hemos tenido es en el año 2008 en el
año 2001 tuvimos un terremoto de
magnitud 8 punto 4 y con una profundidad
de 33 kilómetros esto qué cosa quiere
decir que la ruptura se generó en 33
kilómetros en el fondo marino entonces
ahí se generaron evidentemente son
también relativamente grandes nos fuimos
a visitar la zona de arequipa en este
tiempo vivimos fue nivel de inundación
hasta 6 metros
imagínate una panza de agua de 6 metros
de altura que esté entrando a una costa
es realmente impresionante
entonces como hacemos el andaluz porque
tenemos que ahora es evidenciar cuáles
son las fuentes sísmicas es decir cuáles
son las zonas las cuales o en las cuales
hay una mayor probabilidad de que haya
una ruptura que federico sismo y
posteriormente un funcionario el perú
está dividido en varias zonas sísmicas
que se llaman la fuente sísmica pero
obviamente no todas ellas a producir no
son también las que van a producir los o
también son aquellas que están frente a
la costa peruana es decir aquellas
fuentes hídricas de estas de color verde
y que cuando tendríamos
como resultado tendríamos un modelo que
representaría cómo se rompería esa zona
en el fondo marino el cual luego
generaría un sótano acá por ejemplo este
modelo que presentó al inicio del vídeo
con el profesor y más mural lo hemos
trasladado ahora al perú como un grupo
de investigadores del 6000 se generó
este modelo de esos trabajos que se hizo
no solamente para la costa de lima
especialmente fue para analizar cuáles
serían las consecuencias de inundación
para la zona oeste del aeropuerto porque
chávez ustedes saben
se va a ampliar la valoro tanto la
segunda pista en el aeropuerto jorge
chávez y vamos a ver entonces lo que
podría pasar entonces tenemos el
escenario si con diferentes magnitudes
obviamente no sabemos cuál es la
magnitud vital que va a ocurrir
la ecuación arioso también entonces lo
que se hace es un análisis de
sensibilidad y estas son dando estos
cuadrados pequeños que deben ahí
identifican una sub zona de ruptura o
sea cada cuadradito
nos va a tener un desplazamiento
diferente toda la zona que va a generar
el terremoto y generamos qué cosas es en
varios cívicos para diferentes
magnitudes y estos escenarios síndicos
de diferentes magnitudes trabaja generar
diferentes tamaños de eso también acá
por ejemplo se han hecho simulaciones
desde una magnitud de 8.5 hasta una
magnitud de 9
acá tenemos los colores indican ese
desplazamiento que va a tener ese fondo
marino el cual al final se va a
representar en una ola como vamos a ver
en esta maqueta
tenemos como ven ustedes ahí los colores
van cambiando se van haciendo más
intensos y eso qué cosa quiere decir que
el desplazamiento en el fondo marino va
siendo cada vez mayor
85 86 87 88 89 y entonces en los ojos
necesarios y aunque son de una manera
probabilística se sacan estos escenarios
sísmicos para luego pasar a la siguiente
etapa que es ya la generación del
sudario
muy bien acá tenemos una simulación
frente a las costas del este es el
trabajo también que se hizo con la
cooperación técnica japonesa en donde
usted ve en el lado izquierdo todo el
escenario de la costa peruana en el lado
derecho un detalle para el distrito de
la punta y la zona del callao y algo
interesante que me gustaría que bojan es
el gráfico que está quitándose que va de
color azul a color rojo
vamos a regresar
tigre hay una línea roja que empieza por
debajo del 0 eso qué cosa quiere decir
que inicialmente el mar se va a retirar
y una vez que ocurre ese retiro
todo ya viene la ola en realidad esos
tres de horas como ustedes ven en el
gráfico es un tren de olas que va a ir
rondando poco a poco la costa entonces
justamente ese detalle que queríamos
hacer acá para la costa peruana
entonces cuál es acá desde ese gráfico
qué cosa estamos viendo nosotros estamos
en la línea de costa sentimos un
movimiento sísmico y vemos que el mar se
retira inmediatamente hay que evacuar y
como ya evacuar cierta es la línea de
costa no nosotros nos vamos a evacuar de
esta manera de manera paralela no
siempre que evacuar de manera
perpendicular para alcanzar lo más
rápido posible con una cota o un nivel
de altura el cual me permita estar de la
inundación
cuánto tiempo tenemos más o menos
tenemos en el tiempo por ejemplo en
japón más o menos la distancia entre qué
ocurrió el sismo y la costa más o menos
era como 45 50 kilómetros en cuánto
tiempo llegó la primera ola de 20
minutos acá estamos suponiendo que tal
vez el epicentro ocurre un poco más
lejos más o menos a 70 80 kilómetros
frente a las costas del imán y eso nos
da un poco más de tiempo tendríamos más
o menos como media hora para poder
evacuar a que irán caminamos nosotros
nos caminamos caminamos a 5 kilómetros
por horas y corremos más o menos a todos
sus 13 kilómetros por hora entonces lo
que tenemos que hacer es justamente lo
que se hizo el día luz los simulacros de
evacuación para conocer cuáles son las
rutas de evacuación para tomar la
empresa en el menor tiempo posible y
obviamente alcanzar un nivel en el cual
nos sentamos a salvo
6 el análisis ya un poco más de detalle
como le decía para la zona oeste del
aeropuerto jorge chávez pero acá hay
algo muy importante para hacer el
modelamiento del tsunami no solamente
que conocer la forma del fondo marino
sino también la topografía superficial
para modelar y para conocer cuál es la
zona que va a ser inundada obviamente
esta topografía que es la forma del
terreno no si tenemos por ejemplo si
vamos a la costa verde tenemos un
acantilado de más o menos 30 metros
obviamente eso se tiene que considerar
para hacer esta circulación y estamos en
la zona del callao el personal que yo
ven bastante plana entonces esa forma
del terreno tiene que ser considerada
para hacer esta simulación de la
inundación y para eso hemos trabajado
con rpp ar o comúnmente llamados
andrógenos
rp a viene del sistema aéreo piloteado
remotamente entonces lo que hicimos fue
llevar a todo un equipo de trabajo a la
zona d
a la zona oeste del aeropuerto y con
estos drones actualizar todas bastante
fotografías y luego ya para el proceso
de restitución de la institución el cual
me permite conocer no solamente la
imagen actual la sala de estudio sino
también me permite conocer la topografía
del lugar y tenemos este resultado que
ya es un modelo tridimensional de toda
esa zona de estudio y como ven usted y
bien se puede identificar los tipos de
edificaciones la ventaja de tener este
digamos atendiendo analogías esta
tecnología ya que nos permite hacer vía
el modelamiento en tres dimensiones y
obviamente conocer cuál es esta forma
del terreno eso se le llama la
topografía no solamente eso sino también
conocer cuál es la ocupación de esa zona
y posteriormente identificar las rutas
de evacuación
acá inclusive si ustedes se dan cuenta
por ahí ellos los barcos hay unos
artilleros que están en actividad no sé
si serán este legales o no pero con esta
información podemos hacer ese
modelamiento de la inundación
aquí están ya los escenarios fíjense
ustedes para los diferentes sitios
estos son los secretarios de notación
este es de para una una ilustración con
una magnitud de circo de 8.5 8 puntos 6
8 puntos 7 8 puntos 8 8 puntos 9 y 9 y
como ven ustedes esa línea negra que
venga al lado izquierdo la pista actual
está al lado derecho la pista nueva está
al lado izquierdo con la magnitud del
film a la segunda pista podría verse
afectada pero veamos el modelo de vídeo
y ahí tenemos ya la simulación en tres
dimensiones de toda esa zona ahora como
verán ustedes esta zona la zona inferior
una zona que está poblada ahí está
la base naval van a ver ustedes es la
que se nota más rápido porque porque en
esta zona del lado norte la gente ha ido
rellenando poco a poco yo rellenando y
el nivel inicial que estaba a esto
digamos natural en este nivel no hasta
llegaba hasta 78 metros de relleno claro
que eso ha servido como una especie de
defensa no pero tal vez con el módico el
movimiento sísmico y con esta zona que
es bastante húmeda
tal vez ahí estas viviendas puedan
colapsar por las malas condiciones del
terreno
y la siguiente
ahí tenemos el legendario máximo
probable
en realidad no creemos que ocurra un
sismo de magnitud 9 realmente no creemos
que vaya a ocurrir eso mismo de 856 tal
vez de 9 no creemos no de todas maneras
si antes las circulaciones para ver cuál
podría ser el efecto de ese sismo en
este caso la generación del tsunami para
este sismo frente a las costas de lima
entonces pero el aiún acaben rolen a que
la solución hay que presentarla y la
solución es las rutas de evacuación
y acá tenemos la propuesta para las
rutas de evacuación y justamente esta
información se le da a la población para
que los procesos de
evacuación para que los procesos de
circulación en las convocatorias y
asselin tesis para hacer los simulacros
haya una participación en la población
de manera adecuada y que respete no la
información que se le da de manera
técnica está por ejemplo es una
información para que puedan salir
indicando cuáles son las calles por
donde deben evacuar a la población para
llegar a la zona segura
no sé si notan pero hay una línea azul
resulta en la línea de anotación máxima
no y por eso que estamos poniendo
colocando de esa zona o esas líneas de
evacuación casi vertical y como se dan
cuenta casi verticales a la línea de
costa para que puedan evacuar de manera
rápida y puedan alcanzar un nivel de
terreno lo suficientemente alto como
para que no les afecte la inundación
muy bien finalmente hay lecciones
aprendidas hay muchas lecciones
aprendidas le puedes hacer clic por
expiración
entonces lo primero que tendremos que
hacer es la evacuación
primero alcanzar zonas altas para salvar
la vida algo interesante allí es que los
japoneses no no se preocupan tanto del
vecino también porque porque ellos saben
que el vecino sabe por dónde ir y eso se
trabaja constantemente no frecuentemente
y hay las congestiones
bueno eso se trabaja constantemente con
la sociedad y eso lo que tratamos de
hacer en permítenos centro de
sensibilización y transmitimos todas
estas enseñanzas y aprendizajes que
hemos tenido como experiencias por
ejemplo si ustedes están en la playa
aquí en el auto la peor forma de salir
es en auto como ya vieron los autos
genera congestión más accidentes y
obviamente obstruirían las zonas con las
rutas de evacuación y el gas no lo que
menciona es en el caso de japón ellos
tenían ya ha hecho sus mapas de acción
como nosotros lo tenemos hemos
presentador sin embargo lo que menciona
y el investigador el profesor imamura es
que esos planos de anotación van a tener
que ser revisados porque porque
realmente con el sismo que hubo en el
año 2011 no se sobrepasaron todas esas
estimaciones y la zona inundación abarcó
mucho más área del área que estaba
planificada como área de inundación
entonces por eso que como les decía no
hay que hacer estas simulaciones de con
diferentes
y tú de sismos para poder ver qué cosas
o para poder estimar cuáles son estas
áreas de inundación e identificar las
rutas de evacuación lo más rápido
posible muy bien para terminar no
quisiera mostrarle esta maqueta es muy
interesante esta línea negra que ustedes
ven acá representa la forma del fondo
amarillo esta es la línea de costa y acá
la zona de habitación con la zona de
playa pero la zona de playa no sé si lo
puedan notar pero vamos a generar un
ciclo y si usted de la nave esta línea
de agua con la superficie del agua
primero lo que va a hacer es retroceder
retrocede y luego viene la inundación
entonces en algunos casos que hacen
sistemas de protección acá por ejemplo
tenemos este un sistema de protección
frente a la playa lo que reduciría la
afectación de la inundación detrás de
este sistema de protección pero lo que
pasa en japón fue lo siguiente que el
sismo fue tan grande
qué pasó todos los sistemas de
protección entonces justamente pero como
habíamos notado la inundación debido al
terremoto toma tiempo 20 25 30 minutos o
más dependiendo de la distancia que hay
entre presencia del sismo
y dónde estoy yo como o como poblador
entonces para eso por ejemplo todas
estas toda esa información las mostramos
en esta sensibilización para que puedan
justamente conocer como de manera
práctica y sencilla podemos conocer los
resultados de una circulación de
inundación y el trabajo de civilización
a la población es muy importante es
constante y nos acaba muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]